do you see similarities in the way harry
and megan left the royal family to the
way that diana left
there was one standout moment where
harry gave a speech
for center barley one of the charities
that he's affiliated with
just after making the announcement to
step back and he spoke about
why it is that they were making this
move and thanking people
who had been part of their journey so
far when i lost my mum 23 years ago
you took me under your wing you looked
out for me for so long
but the media is a powerful force and my
hope is one day
our collective support for each other
can be more powerful
because this is so much bigger than just
us
together you have given me an education
about living
and this role has taught me more about
what is right and just than i could ever
have imagined
thank them for the education that they
had given him and i remember at the time
thinking that the words really familiar
and
i looked back at that speech that diana
gave after charity engagement when she
officially stood back from her official
public duties
and the words almost mirrored each other
when i started
my public life 12 years ago
i understood the media might be
interested
in what i did but i was not aware
of how overwhelming that attention would
become
nor the extent to which it would affect
both my public duties and my personal
life
in a manner that's been hard to bear
it was like harry had gone back and
looked up what his mother had said at
such an important time in his life
because of course he can't ask her for
that advice himself so
he instead looks at the path that she
already took on and so
there are these moments where we see a
similarity in the decision she makes and
i'm sure that that
in itself makes harry realize that he is
doing the right thing that his mother
would approve
at the end of this year when i've
completed my
diary of official engagements i will be
reducing
the extent of the public life i've led
so far
we are taking a leap of faith so thank
you for giving me the courage
to take this next step as proud as we
all were
to see you know megan become our
american princess
and especially as women of color to see
a woman who looks like
us for the most part and become a member
of the royal family
um we were also holding our breath
because we knew the moments of racism
become
we could see it a mile away i thought it
was interesting
that in the book you you had mentioned
when harry first started seeing what was
going on he was
i think the word you used was
incandescent um
with anger um part of me said i get it
the other part of me
thought what did they expect did they
really not expect
this i think for the couple they knew
what kind of criticism
lay ahead she was a biracial american
former actress marrying into the house
of windsor and
that ticked all the boxes that were
going to ruffle feathers
but i think for harry and megan to
really witness that up close and for
harry for the first time in his life to
see someone that he loved dearly
be on the receiving end of racist
attacks
would have been very disturbing for him
and and immediately in that moment we
saw him jump into this very
protective mode that i would argue that
he hasn't dropped
ever since we only have to look at the
relationship he had with his mother and
how close he was to diana
and how much that her death affected him
i would imagine that this is a chance
for him to protect a woman
in a way that he wasn't able to perform
all you need to do is focus
focus on on being real and focus on
being the people that we are
um and standing up for what we believe
in i will you know i will not
i will not be bullied into into into
playing a game that killed my mum
so when we hear harry talking about not
wanting to play the games that his
mother did
he really does worry or fear for the
worse for megan i think there are times
where
they were both really fearful of how bad
things could get there were threats
coming to the palace
uh there's conversations online were
extremely
toxic even on the own the royal social
media
it got pretty dicey and so i would
imagine for the couple
wanting to get away from that and sort
of re-establish things on their own
terms
would have been really important do you
think he sees his mom
and meghan a lot i think there's a level
of protectiveness that harry has towards
megan and
archie because of what he saw happen to
his mother
he realizes how easy it is for an
individual's life to be turned
upside down in the most tragic of ways
and
he's determined for that not to happen
to his own family and so
some may argue that that has led to an
extra layer of sensitivity
that he is perhaps a bit more uh aware
of some of these things that take place
or could happen to his family than
others
but i think if anything he's also grown
up within the institution he knows what
goes on behind the scenes he knows that
not
everyone has the best intentions
of other members of the royal family at
heart and so he really wanted to protect
megan from getting wrapped up
in what he saw as sort of a viper's nest
of
men in grey suits and people that didn't
always have their best interests at
heart
i think transparency was always
something really important to diana and
it's something we haven't seen
a lot of in the recent months or the
past few years with harry and megan and
their treatment of them
within the royal family diana would have
stood up for them
and she would have seen the position
there and it mirrors
some of the challenges that she faced
within the institution too
you